all right
hey guys it's me jasmine we are here at
sushi ginza onodera a two michelin star
restaurant we're gonna speak with chef
johay and he's gonna show us a little
bit about aging fish a super super
traditional process that dates back to
200 years ago let's go check it out
like a party in my mouth
[Laughter]
americans are obsessed with fresh sushi
we want the fish to be caught prepared
and placed on our plate all on the same
day but in order for that delectable
piece of toro to go from boat to tongue
it has to travel a long way so how do
you preserve that fresh taste that we
all crave well by freezing it is
there are many ways to age fish but the
four main techniques in edomai sushi are
one kombuchime salted seaweed marinade
two shoyuzuke a soy sauce marinade three
tsujime a pickling vinegar marinade and
four nimono cooking the fish
[Music]
first seaweed is rehydrated using sake
until soft
then the fillet is salted and wrapped in
the seaweed like a blanket then left to
age for four days
kochi is a white fish with similar
texture to the puffer fish
[Music]
that was so good there's like a bounce
to it it's like christmas every 30
seconds
[Music]
the salmon is quickly poached in a bath
of hot water and cooled in an ice bath
to prevent cooking all the way through
then the filet is placed in a marinade
of homemade soy sauce mirin and dashi
then aged for one night
[Music]
melts in my mouth and i know it's aged
but it just tastes so so fresh thank you
so much
[Music]
after the fish is filled it's placed in
a strong salt water bath for 10 minutes
to remove that strong fishy smell
the skin is torched very slightly and
placed in a bowl of vinegar for 30
minutes
after the skin is scored and topped with
original japanese tiger shrimp powder
like a party in my mouth
[Laughter]
[Music]
the eel is filleted then placed in hot
water to remove slime on the skin
then it's cooked in a soup base for 30
minutes
the soup paste is kept and used over
again each time enriching the flavor and
thickness of the broth
[Music]
so different
taking in the entire process it doesn't
just start here it starts with the
fisherman and then you come in prep and
do all this beautiful stuff in between
and you say that the process ends with
the customer eating it it's like a whole
story and you were saying how
it's like an open book we see everything
so seeing the love and care that goes
into each single piece of fish i think
that really makes it that sets it apart
from everything i
you eat
you eat smoothie this is
[Music]
you